I've never met a billionaire that's good
with women all of them suck Google their
girlfriends or wi story it's all
horrific stories right but that's
because they're so focused on making
money they don't understand like how
personal relationships work right most
billionaires were bullied Elon Musk he
was horribly bullied it's a sad story
and so they want to make money to get
the status to get the women and then
they never got good with the women and
then they get the money they move to
Beverly Hills you never date any girl
from Beverly Hills guys are like I'm
rich now I'm like bro you're getting the
cream of the gold diggers generally
speaking the dating pool that wealthy
people are interested in the internal
qualitative factors are worse like Jack
might do better being worth 2 million
than 100 million in terms of finding a
partner all billionaire suck with
movement